[Musique]
aujourd'hui à l'émission fonte des
glaciers accéléré dans les rocheuses
était de plus en plus est dans les
prairies contre toute attente certaines
terres du canada ont soif mais quels
sont les impacts sur l'agriculture
un grand dossier sur l'une de nos plus
précieuse ressource
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte le
canada possède 20% des réserves d'eau
douce de la planète pour plusieurs c'est
une ressource quasi inépuisable c'est ce
qui explique peut-être pourquoi nous
sommes les plus grands consommateurs
d'eau au monde et aussi pourquoi très
peu de politiques existent pour gérer
cette ressource
pourtant les pénuries d'eau sont déjà
bien réelle à plusieurs endroits au pays
[Musique]
l'école c'est moche
normalement cette récolte atteindrait ma
taille
si on est chanceux
nous aurons un tiers de notre rendement
moyen
[Musique]
a beau être optimiste de nature le
manque d'eau commence à peser lourd sur
son moral
ce fermier du sud de l'alberta dépend de
la pluie pour ses cultures mais au début
juillet 2021 la pluie se fait rare et il
fait chaud très chaud
nous savons que nous sommes dans un
climat plus sec
dans le sud de l'alberta nous disons que
nous cultivons dans un désert et nous y
sommes habitués aux lyonnais
il est normal de connaître deux années
de sécheresse consécutive mais au cours
des cinq dernières années nous en avons
eu quatre l'an dernier nous avons une
excellente récolte et nous voilà encore
en période de sécheresse a new show
famille c'est très inhabituel pour moi
des chiens c'est sans précédent nous
connaissons une sécheresse d'un océan à
l'autre from coast cost
de l'île de vancouver aux prairies
jusqu'à l'ontario et le sud du québec
d'habitude on une sécheresse qui va
durer un mois deux mois maximum et le
stade mais on a pris quatre mois
consécutifs
cette année c'est incroyable en fait on
a vu des bons niveaux record on n'avait
jamais observées ce
qui est encore plus surprenant c'est
cette canicule record qui a accompagné
cette sécheresse
westra août
on a eu trois jours de ce fait à 47
degrés maximum
[Musique]
l'hydrologue john pommereuil est une
sommité mondiale en études de l'eau
depuis des années il dirige des
recherches sur l'eau partout dans le
monde au canada ils travaillent surtout
dans les rocheuses
c'est un centre de recherche que nous
avons établies dans les rocheuses
canadiennes
nous sommes au point le plus élevé du
bassin de la rivière saskatchewan
l'eau qui s'écoule ici fourni de 70 à 80
% du débit de tous les affluents de la
rivière saskatchewan
le bassin hydrographique de la rivière
saskatchewan est vaste et très important
plusieurs de ces rivières prennent leur
source dans les rocheuses qu elle dévale
en direction des prairies alimentant au
passage les villes de calgary et
d'edmonton en eau potable de là elle
traverse l'alberta la saskatchewan et le
manitoba avant de se jeter dans le lac
winnipeg qui se déverse en direction de
l'habitude sont
[Musique]
si rivière irriguent les terres
agricoles
elles fournissent de l'eau potable et de
l'électricité ou ville
en plus d'alimenter tous les écosystèmes
aux alentours le même hydriques sont
rares
[Musique]
quand vous allez à saskatoon et que vous
voyez la rivière saskatchewan sud
seulement 1 % du débit de cette rivière
provient de la saskatchewan
le reste vient d'ici
les rocheuses sont donc une immense
réserve d'eau
la quantité des précipitations les
accumulations de neige et la qualité des
glaciers ont un impact direct sur les
niveaux d'eau partout dans l'ouest
canadien est l'équipe de john pommereuil
étudient cette réserve d'eau
[Musique]
c'est un observatoire hydrologiques nous
surveillons la source des cours d'eau
grâce aux accumulations de neige et aux
glaciers dans les montagnes
ici de la glace et du pergélisol et à
mesure que ceux-ci font dès que la pluie
tombe cela favorise le débit des cours
d'eau en voisin car
[Musique]
nous avons une multitude d'instruments
de mesures climatiques et
météorologiques
nous mesurerons l'épaisseur et la
densité de la neige et la rapidité de la
fonte de celle ci
il s'agit donc probablement du site de
mesure de neige le plus instrumenté au
canada
les données recueillies par tous ces
instruments confirme que les changements
climatiques ont un impact sur le régime
hydrologique des rocheuses grâce à ces
données l'équipe peut concevoir des
modèles et des simulations et ainsi
faire des prévisions hydrologiques et
tout cela n'a rien de rassurant
nous risquons d'avoir un peu plus de
précipitations en moyenne dans les
rocheuses canadiennes mais des
conditions beaucoup plus chaude beaucoup
moins de neige est beaucoup plus de
pluie
les glaciers auront essentiellement
disparu d'ici la fin du siècle
effondrons rapidement au cours des
prochaines décennies
le glacier petto
voici un parfait exemple de l'impact des
changements climatiques
ce glacier est la source du lac petto
l'une des plus belles cartes postales
des rocheuses
c'est le premier glacier au monde à
faire l'objet d'une surveillance
intensive et ce suivi montre une des
glaciations si rapide que son nez
stupéfiants
[Musique]
en 1965 je me serais tenu ici à deux
cents mètres plus haut en altitude
et vous voyez la crête là-bas et bien à
ce moment-là on pouvait marcher
directement sur la glace
cela démontre à la fois visuellement et
scientifiquement l'impact des
changements climatiques
sunrise
[Musique]
nous sommes au bord d'une crevasse où le
glacier se brise cela aurait été une
promenade à si agréable il ya quelques
années à peine mais il y a un an il y a
eu un effondrement
pour un glacier s'est incroyablement
rapide
la chaleur excessive qui a frappé
l'ouest du pays à l'été 2000 21 a eu un
effet radical sur le glacier
[Musique]
nous avons enregistré des températures
de 14 degrés celsius sur la glace ici ce
qui est extrêmement chaud pour un
glacier les vents ils sont généralement
quelques degrés au dessus de zéro
et puis descendre et de la suie
provenant d'un incendie en
colombie-britannique se sont déposés sur
le glacier et en ont assombri la surface
ensuite dézinguer des bactéries ont
rendu la glace encore plus sombre
cette glace noire font très rapidement
on estime que le glacier aura perdu
cette année seulement environ 7 mètres
ce qui est la plus importante perte à ce
jour
[Musique]
le glacis petto comme la centaine de
glaciers encore présents dans les
rocheuses retient les accumulations de
neige et cette neige quand elle fournit
le débit des rivières le glacier agit
comme un thermostat qui contrôle la
température
cela permet de ralentir la fonte de la
neige
[Musique]
mais durant une année de sécheresse
comme celle de 2021 lorsque toutes les
autres sources de débit des rivières se
sont taries
alors la fonte des glaces est tout ce
qui nous reste pour soutenir le débit
des rivières
la fonte du glacier petto et dramatique
avec les prévisions des changements
climatiques voilà peut être un mauvais
présage pour les niveaux d'eau dans
l'ouest du pays
[Musique]
pour moi c'est apocalyptique
ce que nous voyons ici c'est une des
glaciations bien plus rapide que tout ce
que nous avions anticipé
nous savions déjà que ce glacier
n'allait pas survivre au 21ème siècle
mais là nous le voyons fondre beaucoup
plus tôt que prévu je ne pense pas qu'il
va se rendre en 2050 probablement même
pas en 2030
tout ça rend notre approvisionnement en
eau très précaire
[Musique]
baker break ces gens d'années qui peut
mener une ferme à la faillite
ce genre de ces chaises ça arrive et
cela nuit vraiment à l'industrie
pendant longtemps des vides baeck ch'ti
dépend des de la pluie pour ses cultures
mais depuis trois ans cet agriculteur du
sud de l'alberta accès à l'irrigation
on peut maintenant irrigué parce que les
autorités ont fait un très bon travail
de préservation
et cette eau supplémentaire peut être
partagé avec plus d'agriculteurs
[Musique]
c'est une décision évidente cela réduit
sans aucun doute les risques augmentent
le rendement et améliore notre situation
économique
[Musique]
l'irrigation est très importante en
alberta la province possède à elle seule
les trois quarts de tous les systèmes
d'irrigation au canada et la majeure
partie de ce système se trouve dans le
sud de la province l'irrigation assure
une production agricoles performantes
dans une région semi aride
[Musique]
l'irrigation a permis de doubler tripler
voire quadrupler la quantité de
nourriture que cette terre produit
tout cela est très convaincant
pour que tout ce système d'irrigation
fonctionne il faut beaucoup d'eau
nous trouvons devant l'un des principaux
réservoirs d'irrigation
l'eau que vous voyez ici provient des
montagnes rocheuses à l'arrière
bac
comme nous pouvons le voir ce réservoir
est plein hiver 2020 2021 a été traîné
jeunes
le chercheur stéphane kinsley de
l'université devait bridge en alberta
analyse l'apport en eau dans les
prairies du sud de la province en lien
avec l'évolution du climat il a compilé
toutes les données climatiques des 70
dernières années pour tout le territoire
de l'alberta
combien de jours de gel il ya eu combien
de jours en dessous de moins 20 degrés
combien de jours où déçus de 30 degrés
combien de jours de pluie quelle est la
durée d'une saison de croissance au
total de calcul 55 indice climatique
différents
ces données lui permettent d'avoir un
portrait exact des tendances climatiques
son constat est alarmant le climat
change rapidement
ici les hivers sont beaucoup plus courts
qu'auparavant et nous avons une saison
de croissance beaucoup plus longue
dans cette région la saison de
croissance est d'environ trois semaines
plus longue aujourd'hui qu'elle ne
l'était dans les années 50
ce qui va de pair avec des températures
plus élevées est une augmentation des
taux d'évaporation
cela signifie que nous aurons durant
l'été plus de pertes vers l'atmosphère
provenant de sources d'eau tels que le
réservoir ici
mais le plus gros problème est que les
soldes vont se dessécher davantage parce
que nous avons une saison de croissance
plus longue
[Musique]
il est clair pour lui qu'une plus longue
saison de croissance n'est pas une bonne
nouvelle dans un contexte où l'eau se
fait de plus en plus rares
[Musique]
le problème c'est qu'un réservoir
d'irrigation comme celui ci ne contient
contre 1 et 2 en deux au maximum
si nous avions une sécheresse qui devait
durer plus de deux ans alors ces
réservoirs ne fournirait pas
l'histoire a déjà démontré à plusieurs
reprises que des sécheresses sur
plusieurs années peuvent frapper ici
la dernière en tête s'est déroulé durant
les années 1930 il y a également eu les
sécheresses de 2001 et de 2002 qui ont
fait très mal
[Musique]
en examinant les tendances climatiques
des soixante dix dernières années avec
des taux d'évaporation accrue des taux
de précipitation des croissants et des
soldes globalement plus asséché et en
même temps avec des réserves d'eau
insuffisante alors nous avons un énorme
défi de maintien d'un approvisionnement
en eau oui à ce challenge
[Musique]
l'agriculteur david beck ch'ti a profité
il ya trois ans de l'agrandissement du
système d'irrigation en alberta il est
très conscient qu'il a accès à une
ressource limitée 6 pourquoi ils
utilisent toutes les technologies
disponibles qui permettent de réduire la
consommation d'eau
je crois en la conservation nous
utilisons une ressource disponible mais
sans en abuser nous l'utilisons
intelligemment
[Musique]
nous utilisons seulement la quantité
d'eau dont nous avons besoin pour sa
culture jacques arroseurs est muni d'une
puce spécifique qui distribue une
quantité différente à chaque minute
ce sont des sons d'humidité du sol que
j'ai installé
les utilisent pour gérer le système
d'irrigation
quelle est la quantité d'eau de pluie
les niveaux des bateaux transpiration la
quantité d'eau que la culture utilisent
nous nous assurons et les plans ne
manque pas d'eau ou ne reçoivent pas
tout
il y à des technologies que nous
n'utilisons pas encore mais qui je pense
ont un jour très utile l'irrigation
goutte à goutte par exemple fourni
l'exacte quantité d'eau dont la plante a
besoin ce système existe mais pas ici
parce que ce n'est pas encore
économiquement viable mais ce sera
peut-être un jour par bobby sands
[Musique]
les eaux qui dévalent les rocheuses en
alberta traverse toutes les prairies
elles servent aux grandes villes à
l'écosystème et aussi à toute une
agriculture mais l'alberta a
l'obligation de partager un minimum
d'eau avec la saskatchewan et le
manitoba un traité géré par le
gouvernement fédéral stipule que
l'alberta doit laisser 50% de
d'écoulement naturel des rivières à la
saskatchewan qui à son tour doit laisser
passer 50 % du débit vers le manitoba
c'est un accord très simple mais en
pratique c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
car 50% de pas grand chose ça donne très
peu surtout si vous vous situez en aval
a string
la saskatchewan veut aussi agrandir son
système d'irrigation pour améliorer sa
propre production agricole
un projet de 4 milliards de dollars
propose de dériver plus d'eau du lac
diefenbaker une eau qui provient aussi
de l'alberta
il ne faut pas oublier que l'eau est une
ressource limitée si elle nous semble
plus abondant en ce moment c'est en
raison de la fonte des glaciers cette
plus grande quantité d'eau peut faire
croire qu'il y en aurait assez pour
étendre les zones d'irrigation mais nous
devons faire attention il faut examiner
la variabilité des futurs débit des
rivières et leur capacité à soutenir
tous les usages
il
la rivière milk dans l'extrême sud de
l'alberta est un bon exemple des défis
de gestion de l'eau cette rivière prend
sa source dans les rocheuses du montana
entre en alberta pour ensuite retourner
vers les états unis où elle se jette
dans la rivière missouri une entente
entre le canada et les états-unis gère
le partage de l'eau de la rivière milk
les canadiens ont droit à 25 % du débit
mais en juillet 2021 tous les
agriculteurs du nord de la frontière
doit fermer le robinet de l'irrigation
car n'y a pas assez d'eau dans la
rivière c'est la troisième fois en cinq
ans que cela arrive
cette fermeture nous ne l'anticipions
pas aussitôt que le 9 juillet
coupez-les aussi rapidement va diminuer
nos récoltes de 25 à 40%
[Musique]
nous devons faire quelque chose et nous
devons le faire maintenant l'eau est
cruciale elle est notre futur
nous devons assurer notre
approvisionnement en eau si nous voulons
garder nos gens et nous ferme ici
il y à plus de 100 ans la rivière milk
était la source du tout premier conflit
d'usagé d'eau entre le canada et les
états unis
ce conflit a mené à la création de la
commission mixte internationale qui gère
toutes les eaux frontalières telle la
rivière milk mais aussi les grands cours
d'eau comme le fleuve columbia les
grands lacs où le fleuve saint laurent
larivière milk est un indicateur de ce
que nous pourrions éventuellement voir
ailleurs lorsque la stabilité hydrique
est compromise par le manque de neige et
de glace
nous savons maintenant à quoi ressemble
de vraie pénurie d'eau c'est loin d'être
laid
[Musique]
la vallée de l'okanagan connu pour ses
paysages ses vins ses fruits et sa
qualité de vie
[Musique]
mais depuis quelques années l'okanagan
est mieux connue pour ses extrêmes
climatiques
c'est un record absolu qui a été battu
hier il a fait plus de 46 degrés en
colombie britannique
on a un peu paniqué on a eu un peu peur
comment la vigne allait réagir parce que
vraiment en 22 ans de carrière j'ai
jamais vu ça
this is the white house in c'est du
jamais vu la chaleur est arrivé très tôt
et d'une intensité qu'on avait jamais
qu'une des sisters et
la fréquence des événements extrêmes au
monde exactement ce que nos projections
climatiques nous disait mais cela arrive
un peu plus tôt privée
ma névrose explique
denise née au sud a étudié l'évolution
du climat en lien avec la gestion de
l'eau et le développement agricole
pendant des décennies dans la vallée de
l'okanagan
au cours des dix à quinze dernières
années nous avons enregistré plus de
journée au dessus de 30 et 35 degrés
celsius ce sont des conditions vraiment
stressante pour plusieurs cultures
la vallée de l'okanagan dispose d'un
climat semi aride et même désertique par
endroits surtout dans le sud de près de
la frontière américaine en son centre il
y a le grand lac okanagan
long de 120 km cela que donne
l'impression que la ressource en eau a
bondi 6 mais ce n'est pas le cas car ce
lac comme bien d'autres lacs au pays est
un vestige de la dernière grande
glaciation
l'eau qui alimente le lac est acheminée
depuis les montagnes environnantes par
un réseau de petites rivières
derrière moi vous pouvez voir le
ruisseau child il s'agit du deuxième
plus importante affluents du lac
okanagan il est assez évident d'après sa
taille que notre approvisionnement en on
est faible
environ 80% des précipitations de cette
région est perdu par évapotranspiration
dans l'écosystème donc à la fin de tout
ce cycle ce n'est qu'à environ 7% de
l'eau qui est tombée sur la vallée qui
coule naturellement dans les rivières
c'est très peu il faut donc la gérer
très très soigneusement
tout comme dans le sud de l'alberta la
vallée de l'okanagan compte sur un
important réseau d'irrigation pour
s'approvisionner en eau c'est en fait
l'un des plus vieux au pays
[Musique]
tous les utilisateurs d'eau de la vallée
que ce soit les villes les industries ou
les exploitations agricoles doivent
détenir un permis qui stipule la
quantité d'eau à louer
voici notre prise d'eau du ruisseau mais
sean nous prélevons environ 75 % du
débit pour la consommation humaine elle
reste retourne à l'écosystème
bobo asco jarre l'un des districts
d'irrigation de la vallée ce district
abrite le plus importants affluents du
lac okanagan le ruisseau mais sean situé
au sud de la ville de kelowna
non ce n'est pas très gros
durant les périodes de sécheresse
prolongées ce ruisseau se tarit presque
complètement en aval
l'eau de la rivière proviennent un
réservoir retenu par un barrage en amont
au printemps l'eau de la fonte des
neiges rempli le réservoir puis et
relâché durant la saison estivale
nous avons toujours rempli notre
réservoir
la capacité volume et donc là
le problème c'est que la demande en
hausse et accru depuis alors nous gruge
on nous réserve
et il y à beaucoup d'endroits dans la
vallée qui n'ont pas accès à des
réserves ce qui cause pas mal de stress
présente
le problème est le même qu'en alberta
l'eau dans la vallée de l'okanagan
dépend des précipitations de neige et
les changements climatiques provoquent
beaucoup de variations dans les
précipitations
[Musique]
les prévisions de précipitations sont
imprécises dans les modèles de
changement climatique mais aussi qu'il
ya certaines années où les réservoirs ne
se rempliront pas seul il faudra alors
prendre des décisions et ces jeunes son
aide
if we lost a cru perdre pour deux
semaines au beau milieu de l'été notre
approvisionnement en eau s'entraînerait
des pertes de l'ordre d'un demi milliard
pour la région
cela prouve à quel point ce ruisseau est
important pour l'économie ici il nous
n'avons pas d'autres sources
d'approvisionnement
devant l'urgence de la situation et
surtout avec les événements de l'été
2021 de nombreux agriculteurs et
vignerons mettent les bouchées doubles
pour réduire leur utilisation en eau
c'est le cas de la viticultrice séverine
peinte à oliver dans le sud de la vallée
ici on est dans un désert on a à peu
près
entre 200 mm d'eau par an et 250 mm
d'eau par an ce qui a rien de tout et du
coup on a changé notre système
d'irrigation on est passé en
goutte-à-goutte donc c'est ce qu'on voit
ici
cette technique d'irrigation a pour
effet d'arroser lentement mais de façon
très ciblée à peu près 90% de l'eau qui
est délivrée va actuellement dans le sol
l'équipe fait également des tests de
pression d'eau sur le feuillage ce
travail permet de voir comment les
plantes réagissent à l'apport en nous
donc on mesure la quantité d'eau à une
certaine pression qui va sortir donc dû
pétioles et ça nous permet de voir si
effectivement la plante est très stressé
et donc il faut donner le lot ou si
l'irrigation qu'on a fait pendant la
nuit ou la veille est encore en action
et la plante est modérément stressé du
coup comme on est capable de délivrer de
l'eau de façon précise comme ça on a à
peu près diminué de 50 % la quantité
d'eau qu'on mettait au vignoble donc
c'est énorme
si techniques de test de pression et
d'irrigation au goutte-à-goutte font des
petits partout chez les producteurs de
vins et de fruits de l'okanagan
comme dans les vergers de dv jean l'un
des plus importants producteurs de
cerises de la vallée
il ne fait aucun doute que nous aurons
besoin de plus d'eau dans l'avenir tout
en maintenant la quantité d'eau que nous
pouvons utiliser on pourra répondre à
cette demande si on utilise cette eau
avec parcimonie
depuis trois ans david jean met en
application une nouvelle technique
l'irrigation par déficit c'est à dire
diminuer considérablement l'apport en
nous après la récolte
nous terminons la récolte des cerises
entre la mi juillet et la fin ou et à
mesure que nous terminons dans un
secteur nous y réduisant de 40 à 50 %
l'utilisation tout
les faits et 12 on économise le et on
aide les arbres à se préparer pour
l'hiver
si vous réduisez la quantité d'eau que
vous fournissez à l'abs la réponse de
l'arbre sera d'arrêter sa croissance
c'est comme si le fermer boutique pour
l'hiver c'est donc important s'il ya une
vague de froid précoce à la fin octobre
et en novembre vous voulez que les
arbres est déjà fait la transition
hivernal plutôt pour se protéger
cette privation d'eau est très utile
toutes ces techniques de conservation de
l'eau sont mises de l'avant non par
choix mais par obligation
car la vallée de l'okanagan vite une
croissance de sa population et demande
humaine et son agriculture
le problème c'est que l'offre en eau
elle n'est pas en croissance
de nombreux cours d'eau dans le canadian
sont entièrement dédiés à la
consommation humaine cet aménagement
s'est fait à une époque on ne tenait pas
compte des écosystèmes mais cela a
changé et le problème ne cesse de
s'aggraver
cela devient une question sociale ou
politique la science fourni certaines
réponses mais les décisions finales
appartiennent tout citoyen
voulons-nous il valait de production
alimentaire ou de développement
résidentiel
voulons-nous le statut coup mais tout en
sachant que ça ne pourra pas durer car
les grandes chaleurs que nous avons vécu
ici cette année vont se reproduire
[Musique]
et
s'il ne pouvons pas gérer notre eau
adéquatement je ne sais pas comment les
gens ailleurs au pays pourront le faire
si nous parvenons à partager la
ressource équitablement alors vous savez
je pense que nous serons un modèle pour
le reste du pays
[Musique]
ce noeud rivière connu pour avoir des
étiages sévères autant en été qu'en
hiver les niveaux sont bas la regarder
et large donc les dépenses hors d'eau
sont très faibles
la rivière nicolet en plein centre du
québec rural
comme partout ailleurs au pays la
sécheresse de l'été 2021 a eu ses effets
ici cette année c'est incroyable en fait
on a vu des niveaux bas record on
n'avait jamais observées çà
est ce que c'est la nouvelle réalité est
ce que ça peu sempéré aussi est-ce que
ça va revenir à la normale
mais qu'est ce que le débit normal pour
cette rivière qui approvisionne en eau
plusieurs villes villages et autres
entreprises agricoles
si difficile à croire mais on a peu de
connaissances sur les quantités d'eau
consommés au québec seuls les très
grands préleveur ceux qui puisent 75
mètres cubes d'eau par jour doivent
détenir un certificat d'utilisation
d'eau c'est le cas par exemple des
municipalités on connaît le point de vue
purement théorique les principaux
usagers on connaît où sont installés la
plupart des puits de surface les puits
d'eau souterraine on connaît les points
de prélèvement pour les grandes
industries les muncipalités mais c'est
l'ensemble
l'addition de tous ces prélèvements
alors qu'on ne connaît pas
j'ai aucune idée quelle est vraiment la
portion nature est elle qui coule dans
ce cours d'eau là
le chercheur alain rousseau tente
d'établir un vrai portrait comptabilisé
de l'utilisation de l'eau de la rivière
nicolet
c'est une première au québec pour
vraiment savoir la quantité d'eau
prélevés il faudrait avoir des compteurs
d'eau en tous points de prélèvement
tant et aussi longtemps qu'on n'aura pas
un portrait clair des prélèvements
cumulatif sur les débits en rivière on
ne pourra pas faire une gestion dite
préventive pour se prémunir et se
préparer aux changements climatiques qui
vont augmenter les pressions sur la
ressource en eau
la météo le climat vous provoquez en
fait des sécheresses comme ça puis si on
continue à utiliser
puis à se développer la même façon mais
à un moment donné va avoir un conflit
le canada possède environ 20% des
réserves mondiales d'eau douce de ce
nombre trois pour cent se trouvent au
québec c'est donc normal de croire à
l'abondance de la ressource quand on
voit le nombre de lacs et rivières et
surtout de fleuve saint laurent tant et
aussi longtemps qu'on n'est pas
confronté à des problèmes aigus en
général on ne fait pas grand chose
moi j'ai souvent l'abondance est général
mais il à orthez locale c'est à dire que
ça donne rien dans une communauté où un
individu de savoir que terre capitaux il
ya énormément d'eau au québec si tu en
as pas le calme
le stan lee en a pris quatre mois
consécutifs quand on a eu des manques
d'autres
robert bourdeau et agriculteurs dans le
sud de la montérégie pour lui la
sécheresse de l'été 2021 a été un dur
réveil on a vu les rivières asséchées on
pourra toujours aller pomper des
rivières et lausanne et les rivières et
son ch depuis le début a ou fac aucune
façon d'aller s'approvisionner de l'eau
à ne pas porc lait puis
j'ai vu le fond du puits avec du sable
ou parce que je me suis retrouvé à
pomper plus d'eau que j'étais capable
c'est déjà arrivé par des ânes
auparavant mais on veut jamais que ça
arrive
le sud de la montérégie si le jardin du
québec le coeur de la grande production
maraîchère une agriculture qui a besoin
de beaucoup d'eau mais ici l'on n'est
pas abondante s'il n'y a pas de pluie on
doit se tourner vers l'eau souterraine
car le débit des rivières est faible la
pression sur la ressource en eau est
donc importante un nombre vraiment
important de d'utilisateurs l'initiation
utilisation évidemment municipal
utilisation de résidentiel une session
agricole puis aussi des prélèvements
industriels qui sont un portable
[Musique]
le chercheur rené lefebvre a analysé les
données d'utilisation de l'eau en lien
avec les réserves d'eau souterraines
disponibles son constat est clair le sud
de la montérégie fait face à un grand
défi
les projections d'eau disent que on peut
pas poursuivre dans cette voie là au
niveau de la quantité
de l'usagé qu'on fait la ressource qui
est limité pour soutenir des
développements a pu fini qu'ils soient
démographique urbains et agricoles
il va falloir faire des choix
de l'autre côté du fleuve à lanoraie
même constat
l'usagé de l'eau est trop grand pour ce
que la ressource plutôt offrir
[Musique]
l'enjeu c'est la protection d'une
tourbière
ce milieu humide est entouré de terres
agricoles qui servent entre autres à la
production de pommes de terre grande
consommatrice d'eau au moment où on a
commencé à faire de l'agriculture
industrialisée dans la région qu'on a
modifié le ccri d'euros logique et donc
ça a modifié l'apport d'eau dans la
tourbière
l'hydrologue marie laroque étudie
l'utilisation de l'eau par l'agriculture
et son impact sur cette tourbière on a
vu au fil des années les armes
progresser au sein de la tourbière à
mesure que les espèces ligneuses se met
en place et un cercle vicieux qui
s'installe et plus qu'il ya des espèces
ligneuses plus que les niveaux baissent
parce que niveau baisse plus que des
espèces ligneuses et là ça progresse
pendant très longtemps le québec a
drainé ses terres et assécher ses
milieux humides pour faire place à de
l'agriculture l'eau on ne voulait pas
qu'elle reste
c'est ce qui s'est passé en montérégie
et c'est ce qui est en train de se
produire à lanoraie
et ça on veut le stopper car on connaît
aujourd'hui les bienfaits hydrologiques
de ces milieux tous les milieux et verts
vont ralentir l'eau et faire en sorte
qu'on peut maintenir de l'eau à la
surface plus longtemps
quand il y en a beaucoup quand une
grande matrice de milieux humides sont
un territoire on a cet effet tampon de
retenir les eaux lors des crues de
relâcher l'horreur des étiages
on draine les tourbières on coupe les
armes ont fait des fausses et on
construit des routes qu'il ya de
l'étalement urbain donc on a de moins en
moins cette réserve d'eau lors en
surface et c'est crucial pour nous au
québec
devant ce constat selon l'hydrologue
marie laroque il faut évaluer toutes les
pistes de solutions possibles tête
compte pourrait aller chercher de l'eau
d'une source aussi faire venir de l'eau
du fleuve pour l'irrigation
évidemment il ya des coups qui sont
importants mais il ya des enjeux de
disponibilité de l'eau des enjeux
sociaux aussi est-ce qu'on veut passer
un pipeline dans une région
il ya pas de réponse cinq pas en fait
mais on sait qu'il faut qu'il y ait des
changements si on veut maintenir le mode
de vie des agriculteurs tout en
protégeant le milieu humide
ces
deux lacs artificiels en montérégie
robert bourdeau n'a plus le choix il
doit investir dans la rétention de l'eau
aux 20,6 enregistrée comme l'âge et
commencer à magasiner de l'eau qu'est ce
que je fais à pau avait quelqu'un qui
arrive une sécheresse étendue trop tard
pour commencer a dit on prend lyon où ça
va être de la magazine et au fond des
neiges pour en avoir pour le tri
depuis les dernières années le québec
qui rattrape un retard dans sa
connaissance de ses ressources en eau
potable
ces travaux ont permis de comprendre que
malgré une image d'abondance en eau les
risques de pénurie sont bien réels et
que la ressource en eau qu'elle soit en
rivière ou sous terre ne fait qu'une
l'eau c'est une ressource unique qu'elle
soit souterraines ou de surface parce
que l'eau souterraine fini son parcours
dans les cours d'eau si aux jo qui colle
dans les cours d'eau c'est parce qu'ils
sont alimentés par l'eau souterraine à
quelques pas en avant mais quand on est
rendu au mode où l'eau qui est dans la
rivière se loge terrain
d'essentiellement
[Musique]
que ce soit au québec en alberta en
colombie-britannique où ailleurs au pays
l'eau est vitale
tant pour les citoyens que pour
l'économie
et pour en assurer la saine gestion on
doit viser les mêmes objectifs réduction
de la consommation utilisation plus
précise et surtout partage de la
ressource
nous n'avons pas une approche commune de
gestion
pourtant notre eau provient des
précipitations qui n'ont pas de
frontières
nous partageons lot des grands lacs nous
partageons notre eau mais nous ne
partageons pas la responsabilité de la
gestion de notre eau n ya donc pas mal
l'exportation massive ou le transport
massif d'eau saas fee paul ceci hors de
prix c'est pour ça que ça prend de l'eau
lequel ne puis look on localement ben il
faut la gérer pour garder sa kay type
la communauté scientifique s'est depuis
plusieurs années qu'il y à une crise de
l'eau au canada parce que nous n'avons
pas bien géré la ressource
pays qui possède 20% de l'eau douce
mondiale ne devrait pas avoir une crise
de dubaï world crise
[Musique]